per altri ragazzi prendete questo video
sono parigi oggi l'episodio finale di
minecraft del jump dove dobbiamo
arrivare alla fine abbiamo fatto tutto
sto pezzaccio enorme dall'inizio che sta
li fa tutto quel casino arrivati l'aveva
dato tre tentati qua sotto in quanto è
un casino conservate fino l'acqua ha
davanti il labirinto fatto tutto quello
siamo andati ragioni ghiaccio il fuoco
siamo arrivati abbiamo fatto qualcosa
laggiù i salti lisa in le nuvole fino
qua e siamo arrivati qui oggi vediamo
siano episodi riusciamo a farlo come ci
dovrebbe essere pietro no d'attacco join
the game
noi non può giocavo per studio microchip
regole west al partito il secondo ti
prego ma perché c'è un armatore che vi
parla quando tu entri nel gioco e quando
esce descrivi qualcosa in ciak ti
vengono stesi cosa d'attacco senza scemo
chi legge da dai radar e navigatori dire
cielo ti ascolta narratore che dice
quello che scrivi va bene allora
dobbiamo arrivare alla fine di questo
livello
ce la faremo 6 sodio questa mappa anche
io io basta farò il video non parlando
ma scrivendo che in gran commentari
avverte di pietro l'ex comico minore sky
su con la vita su col morale sugo
immorale senso il farmaco non riesco a
fare questo pezzo non riesco le scale
scale e fiere ce l'ho fatta allora
adesso sulle scale dobbiamo riuscire a
fare questa cosa
ok è uno l'abbiamo fatto in teoria il
giro delle scale è abbastanza semplice
ragazzo è riuscito a farlo ok ce l'ho
fatta un po di lato amico mio tutto
rivelando allora dovremmo arrivare acqua
c'è un altro cubo key 6 no ok allora il
credere in me adesso amico credi meno
dei bei infatti non ho creduto per nulla
lei
che vita brutto ho visto la morte in
diretta per te l'ho visto anch'io
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta a vico ce l'ho fatta
voglio morire alex non smettono il
contratto se funziona c'è poi funzionano
poi cattura per l'occhio ha detto no va
bene non ve l'abbiamo presa c'è poi
nonchè iraq roja proprio prevedere mi
fai il tipo il tipo tifosi mi fa il tifo
scrivi no nos rivinciata ok 77 aspetti
aspettano miglia parti 123 via fa visse
in forza da teco forza da te con forza
da si guarda se cade vial pietro schifo
morivo perché alla fine era tutto
sincronizzato con il risalto e l'ultimo
e dal pietro schifo
secondo era bellissima
no no
no no no no no no
la rai denki prezzi
guardalo le a guardarlo anche speedliner
volta pro gamer
ho fatto la speed run di questo pezzo
nessuno l'ha mai fatto veloci metallico
io spesso un caduto però ok importante
piccoli pezzi
no non si può togliere la fisicità tra
noi due che fastidio
detta così sembra molto gay
la madonna e per la 6 rocky balboa mai
tirato un pugno sono finito bechis ton
ma cosa succeda di chiese mi tiro poi ho
visto livello proviamo e si cela fisica
aumentando l'attesa è veramente funziona
sua tecnica la vetta delle immagini ecco
vedi quella in foto ogni volta se noi
non dobbiamo darle a chi lo ha fatto più
ma l'ho fatto io è vero funziona
scherzavo e come fai ad andare più
avanti come fatto cadere più avanti e
poi perché poi lei mamma mia
aspetto che sono ok non è migliore o
loren
non lo so c'è un passaggio segreto credo
che bel gioco che bel gioco troppo e
mori ok hi point mio amico mila check
point l'udc è morto subito
non va bene così adesso andiamo ancora
più avanti viene amico mio
oddio hai capito da the core of di usa
le mutande no ma non è vero ma parte ma
a parte il partenza ho creduto 18 va
fatta allora occhio a cadere qua che su
tutti il checkpoint mesi esatti di
muoverti ok ma no ma ok ok ok ce l'ha
fatta
o che quando arrivare poi facile
perfetto e adesso deve arrivare dal
quadro arrivo oh mio dio no
era difficilissimo che si è riuscito ma
ti prego marina c'è poi chi era l'ultimo
era difficilissimo amici si può fare è
fattibile dai ragazzi dai dai dai dai
dai ce l'ha fatta mi sono preso
l'avevano preso l'ho preso formativo
voluto la cacca di non averlo preso
aspetta aspetta che la partita sky non
ho visto neanche cosa c'è dopo non mi
metto io però è adesso c'e di turno
suscita aggrapparmi ma ok allora esso
c'è un blocco
ora che non manca molto alla fine
mancano pochissimi pezzi quindi andiamo
convinti buono buono buono no no sono
caduti in 20 tempi diversi dai ok una
volta arrivato qua devo fare attenzione
che devo ma io mi sa che devo saltare da
una scala altra capito o faccio così era
buono anche così amico l'ultimo salto
mamma mia mamma mi ha poi suicidarti sui
cd posso suicidi di banca pochissimo
vedo la fine è più amico vedo la fine è
pieno giorno ti alla fine e per non
credo la luce
manolo la prossima volta che la vicenda
registriamo aiuti che la mappa
recensioni tutto da analisi accurata per
cui basta così fai solo bene dico
abbastanza semplice ragazzi però
dobbiamo arrivare vi ricordo la giudichi
sei stai morendo
ok è che mi piace come te come rocky io
abbraccio cactus co indietro in cui sono
anch'io vi fare questa cosa
dov'è che la si fa a milano allora poi
un salto in diagonale in un casinò però
ci proviamo lo stesso
forse devo fare sì credo che anche a
pietro sta andando bene allora siamo qua
siamo qua perfetto sono sull'ultimo
blocco che voglio provare
e infatti ho fatto benissimo ho fatto
benissimo amico mamma via la potenza del
parco dove le mani la patata a me allora
ci sono le ultime due cose da fare una è
questa tu non mi devi spingere madonna
qui fatto hai fatto con vecchio mentre
cadevi malizia di amici di amici ce l'ho
fatta allora c'è un altro stato l'affare
amico ho fatto anche questo e poi anche
quest'altro mio dio mio dio tutto a
posto
ok ora cavalca mano cosa è successo sei
un po tipo ubriaco tranquilla amico a
rivolge poi ok ok molto bene o male che
ti ho preso non ancora scherzavo soldi
turismo youtube e pensavi che questa
papa fosse facile smar comparire bene
questa cosa finirà adesso con una delle
cose più difficili di minecraft il 5 big
jump che cos'è il 5 di gianpi
no no è quello di prima onore file di
jump ok ultima nota le già five block
jump quello di prima
vabbè ma è scusami l'abbiamo fatto prima
quindi pagati difficili potenza che un
difficilissimo ragazzi veramente
difficile mannaia l'ultimo salto ma non
quella scusami a sinistra li vai vai ti
prova a sparare io porca vacca te che
devi correre nel mentre capitoli sempre
bellissimo darti pugni da dietro sai
tutto è tutta una scusa perché la tv
araba per picchiare vertici ma non
potevo l'assurdo tanto da fare
male da fare non solo se lo fai tu si
guarda ce la fai a punta a sinistra
punta a sinistra fidati di me affidati
dalla mia parola work together together
my friends è finita
l'ultimo pezzo maran e cit perché
comunque non c'è scritto non c'è scritto
da nessuna parte che non lo vuoi fare
i ragazzi non sono veramente contento
woerth great sistema thank you for play
mister ex sistere avevano capito dove
erano ei ragazzi spero che il rito vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio pietro per aver
partecipato e per aver preso le scoppole
ciapet da me in questo mi sta picchiando
ma non si vede perché non ho messo gioco
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzina senza mi
piace lasciare come vi piace anche per
il social comitatone descrizione se
questa questi schiette e non ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo park ora un po più easy
magari è la ragazza
[Musica]